[Music]
hello
good afternoon everybody how lovely for
you
all to be tuning in i'm a comedian
writer actress person um
who's been tasked with a talk called how
to empower with wit
and i've had various failures and
successes in a 35 year span of trying to
tap
into wit as best means to communicate
and even entertain this can be done
through words
gestures delivery or timing
today i'm doing words
and i hope to demonstrate how the use
and practice of wit
in organizations and arenas such as
arts literature government it's not all
going to be lists but this is quite
listed thus far
business charities and maybe even sex
although that's less predictable
can empower both the speaker and the
audience
especially where a lack of which has
previously prevailed along with a lack
of engagement
so it might be handy to define wit
if only to differentiate it from a joke
wit is a natural aptitude
for using words and ideas in a quick and
inventive way to create
humor a joke is a thing that also
intends to cause laughter
but has a set up and a punchline which
offers
some sort of surprise if it's to cause
laughter
wit on the other hand offers a ripple
effect
of ironic recognition as a way of
creating humor
less of a leap you might say and far
less bossy
than having to wait for the punchline
before you feel encouraged
or permitted to laugh i've often
struggled with the tyranny of the
punchline
i get anxious having to wait and follow
the long build up to a gag
and then arrange my face in the right
way to let rip with a reactive laugh
at the right time by which time my
anxiety has
diminished my attention so as a comedian
and eight is
a picture there i'd often share a
dressing room with male comedians who do
joke telling as they
psyched up to go on stage so as a people
pleaser
um i'd be concentrating when to laugh
and forget to psych up myself into a
bucket or otherwise
so in the words of dorothy parker
there's a hell of a distance between
wise cracking
and wit whit has truth in it
wisecracking is simply calisthenics with
words
so she also said the first thing i do in
the morning is brush my teeth and
sharpen my tongue
i just googled some the other one um of
many
scratch an actor and find an actress
so i'd far rather enjoy a more evenly
distributed wordplay without the
pressure
of laughing at the payoff line which has
to be an exaggeration
or a lie for it to be a surprise
so far better a witty stream of
consciousness
which is fast and truthful and
gloriously meaningful
obviously we need both gags underpin a
stand-up routine
but comedians do stand up for a job wit
is about empowerment in an evolving
society
it's so exciting doing a powerpoint and
nerve-wracking but that's fine always do
new things
why does women's wit threaten
so women traditionally i'm doing broad
strokes here
have been more likely to be lusted after
and demeaned than seen
as socially equal but a woman with a
witty tongue
could always offer an impactful blow
with words
this could disarm and be an effective
tool
in self-defense as well as communication
more recently the metoo movement which
achieved a lot
was also accused by some as presenting
women
as being victims within the empowerment
campaign
whatever of your view which is the
opposite
of victim which is to be a dominator
or an instructor or champion so we could
say
that whit offers a tool to being a
leader in a different way
if you ask a group of people why they
might feel threatened by a conversation
or a campaign or a
tv chapter with celebrities or a current
affairs debate
it's usually because they feel excluded
or dominated
which in turn makes them annoyed
especially if they've
invested to listen historically
witty speeches of note tended to be
delivered by someone in authority
someone holding a leadership position
women
have still not caught up with the same
amount of authoritative
or senior positions and where they do
occupy those roles
we still have a society where some
people innately resented
it's still too much of a stretch for
some people to overcome their social
conditioning to be comfortable
with a woman who can disarm an
entrenched debate with their use of
witty words
so interestingly it seems more
acceptable to tolerate women's wit
when it's delivered amongst themselves
socially annexed at a hindu or
women's institute forum and less
comfortable to enjoy
or respond to a woman using wit with
authority when in a mixed setting
these are generalizations and i've been
watching
married at first sight australia which
may be an influence
the polarization of behaviors are there
for the cameras i know that
some men continue i'm just doing the
same men thing
some men continue to undermine women's
witty voices even if it's subconscious
because witty women intrude on the
status quo of male dominance
where women do comedy as a job it's
perceived as being audacious
the fact that she calls herself a
stand-up comedian demonstrates an
already immodest
belief that she thinks of herself as
funny
this challenges deep-seated assumptions
from wider society
obviously if the woman is a clown or
doing funny voices and headscarf and
impressions
then that's less conflicting when it
comes to perception
but a woman just using wit as a tool for
her work
can be seen as a threat but what about
those women who don't do it as a job
i think it's important to see the
benefits that a witty delivery can offer
an evolving
a more equal society for a woman to
prove herself
and be heard wit is her best tool it
gets you closer
to landing your point levity is
attractive
which is having a readiness to access
the brain
perhaps a certain type of man is still
threatened by that
and perhaps there may be some women who
are as well particularly if you take the
position that it's been
socially ingrained to play the role of
being a victim
why would we enjoy our own sex becoming
more dominating
but more good news women's wit doesn't
have to be self-effacing or confessional
either
it can be part of a more dominant
initiative with irony
and subtle ridicule and word play in the
words of muriel spark
ridicule is the only honorable weapon we
have
left some women are using a wit
as a tool to rise above their
self-effacing past
and occupy a similar gladiatorial
position to men
as a means to being effective in the
workplace and relationships
however this good practice is also
double led
are women just copying the gladiatorial
initiative
taking stance of men to get jobs on tv
or
other institutions which has a voice
they may be it may not be
i'd like to think we're not i'd like to
think we don't have to copy men to be
heard
or judged but we don't have to be
self-effacing either
which can achieve a level playing field
of delivery
so when i began in the 80s all the older
male comics played golf
and the newer women comics were in the
minority
and had to compete for space positive
discrimination is present now number
ticking is a thing but deep down why are
some people
still threatened by women's wit how can
we change how we see the world to all
embrace language's most magic
bullet are we ready to encourage a more
equal way of being
we may not be ready for a society where
female comics go off for a game of
chess while the men compete to get
starter slots on the circuit
but we may be bridging a gap as society
evolves
wit shouldn't be the last ingredient of
communication to lag behind
will male comics see their own
opportunities diminish and be threatened
unlikely that there is an unsaid joke
going around that to be white middle
class and male is no longer marketable
other people say you have to earn
your position as more women get parity
in key roles in government health
service tv panel games
we're seeing women harness this magic
tool but
like getting the vote it's not as fast
or as obvious as one might think
if only we could show that whit releases
us
from the constraints of having to be
seen as good as
as being as good as but simply empowered
in our own terms
i've been in zoom meetings recently
where men don't like me making a joke it
could be because of jokes rubbish
highly likely but it also means that a
lot of men just
don't want a woman to be funny on their
watch
it's about control no one likes to be
the butt of a gag
where's the dignity in that but whit can
deliver content with a knowing humility
irony self-ridicule all manner of
interesting layers of delivery
can make a point land without having to
denigrate its target
there's even more need than ever to grab
with and use it to unseat
any notion of unnecessary dominance
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas